scp-682 versus scp-923  can this terrifying mind-melting  satellite finally drive scp-682 off the  edge foundation researchers damaged  scp-682 heavily and took it out to an  isolated field in kansas in order to  find out scp-923 fired down at 682 with  its beam set to intensity level 75 known  to have devastating effects against the  minds of its victims when the blast was  unleashed 682 began screaming and  howling obscenities at the sky and the  foundation then its body began to adapt  growing glowing nodes that fired out its  own beam similar to scp-923's blasts  driving the observing foundation  employees completely insane the test was  considered such a failure that one of  the lead researchers on the scp-682  termination project threatened to do  something redacted to whoever organized  it